IT'S AN ALL CANADIAN MATCH UP I
SENATORS OWN.
SCHUENEMAN HAS BEEN REAL OFF.
DVORAK!
GREAT T .
AND THEN RIGHT AWAYOWN!
AND JAKE ALLEN MADE THE STOP. SS
ON A CHANCE. FRONT.
CENTRED IT.
AND TKACHUK STILL GOT THE
BRADY TKACHUK WHO GOT ONE AWAY
BACK IN.
TKACHUK IS THERE FOR WHITE WITH
THE SHOT.
STOPPED BY AND SCORES!
[GOAL HORN
AND THEN HE FINDS A LOT OF ROOM
UPTIGHT.
OH, SCORES!
WHAT A FEED TO JOSH NORRIS!
WHO FIRES ITT.
AND WHAT A BEAUTIFUL PASS ACROSS
TO MAKE THAT PLAY.
AENTON CENTRED!
AL CONTINUE STOP!
TIERNEYOCK.
IT ENDED UP GOING
HIGHER.
>> HERE'SE.
AND FOR A GUY THAT'S BEEN
RUMOURED TO BE TRADED, D DS
ZONE.
[INAUDIBLE]T LEAVES A WIDE OPEN
TKACHUK.
ZUB FIRES!
JAKE FRONT.
JAKE ALLENEM IT NOT
HERE'S A GOOD EXAMPLE
TIERNEY KNOCKED DOWN.
WIDEMAN LOST HIS STICK.
HERE'S ENNIS IN FRONT.
COMING IN WITH A
ANOTHER PLAYER THAT'S PLAYED
QUITE WELL LATELY, AND
WATSON.
ALL THE WAY BACK FOR
ROOM.
HERE COMES BROWN.
COMES UP WITH A STOP THOUGH, AND
KEEPS THE TWO-GOALIT.
SANFORD GOING TO THEANFORD RIGHN
ENNIS NOW!
ON OTTSS.
AND THAT'S WHY GAUDETTE JUST
TAKES OFF THROUGH THE MIDDLE. M.
WATCH HIM.
HE'LL TAKE A PEEK WALKING IN!
SCORES!
[GOAL HORN]
S THE INSIDE OUT PLAY AND
THE EDGE IN THE MIDDLE THIS AFT.
AND PUCK SAVE MADE BY, ISN'T IT?
THE FRUSTRATION BY THE CAPTAIN
ON ONE